ANKUR KOTWAL: Good morning,
ladies and gentlemen.
Welcome to day three of
Google I/O. How are we doing?
Tired.
Well, I hope--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Did
you party last night?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Well, I hope
that this session will
get you inspired and excited.
I'm Ankur Kotwal and I'm a
developer advocate from Sydney.
This is Laurence Moroney, the
star of "Coffee with a Googler"
based out of Seattle.
He's also a developer advocate.
And we're on the Google Maps
API, the developer relations
team, and today we have an
interesting talk for you.
We've taken a different
approach to what we've
done in the past with our APIs.
But I'm going to start
off by telling you
a little bit about the history
of the Google Maps API.
This is a blog post that
we launched 10 years ago,
and it was us announcing
the Google Maps API.
We were really, really
excited to make the Maps
API available to the
world, but we were really
impressed with just how
innovative developers were
with it.
The types of
experiences that you all
built was just astounding,
and that really inspired
us to add more and more
capabilities to the Maps APIs
as time went on.
And so just a quick sort of
historic tour through this.
You can see how the
Maps API has changed,
and these are clearly
the JavaScript Maps APIs.
And this is where we landed
on just a couple of years ago.
So today what we
want to do is talk
about that full set of APIs that
we have, but from a perspective
of where do I get started?
Which API should
I use when I want
to build certain types
of user experiences?
And to support that,
we've developed
a framework, a
four-layer framework,
and we're going to start
going through these layers
in a minute.
But really, with
this framework, you
get to decide how much code you
want to write and balance that
off with what type of
customizability you want.
So I'm now going to hand
it over to Laurence,
who's going to start
walking us through this.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thank you, Ankur.
And good morning
again, everybody.
Now, I don't know about you,
but I'm a really, really lazy
developer.
I like to do as little
work as possible
and get as much benefit
from that work as possible.
That's why I'm probably
doing a talk at 9:00 o'clock
in the morning after the party.
So when talking about building
maps, the first level--
and the one that
appeals to me a lot,
you know, in being able
to do this-- is what we've
been calling the
Delegate Layer, and what
the Delegate Layer
is let someone else
do the work for me.
In this case, it's if I
want to build something
that incorporates a map, I'm
going to say, you know what?
I'm going to have
Google do all the work.
I don't want to do
anything myself.
And what technologies
are available for that
so that I can have
maps, I can have
geo stuff in my
application, without me
doing a whole lot of work?
And in some cases,
not doing any?
So the first one is let's
just use the Google Maps app.
So if I have an
application and I
want to put a map
into it, instead
of embedding a map
myself, I'm going
to launch the Google Maps app.
In Android we do
this using intents.
So when I have an
intent and there
is a URI structure that works
within the Google Maps app,
so if I say geo colon
and a couple of numbers--
anybody know what
these numbers are?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Pick me.
Pick me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Go on, then.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Latitude
and longitude.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Latitude and longitude.
Which one's the latitude?
Which one's the longitude?
ANKUR KOTWAL: The first
one is the latitude.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Very good.
Wasn't it with
Google Maps they used
to be the other way around
in the beginning, right?
It was longitude then latitude.
I learned that this week.
So if I start, like, with
a geo colon something
and I give it a
latitude and a longitude
and then I start up a
map intent from that,
and this map intent is
set to use the package
com.google.android.apps.maps,
now
it's a case of what Android will
do is it will launch the Google
Maps app for me, it
will pass this URI
to it, which is geo colon
latitude, longitude, and that
will render a map
centered on that latitude
and longitude for me.
So now by just putting these
four lines of code in here,
I'm able to get a map of
a location that I want.
Lazy developer like
me, this is great.
I haven't had to
really implement much.
But because we're
using this URI,
and you can see it's
prefixed by geo,
we get the latitude
and longitude,
there's lots of other stuff in
the URI that we can do as well.
So here now I've added
a parameter at the end,
?q=restaurant.
So go on, Ankur, what
do you think the q is?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Query?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Query.
Very good.
So I'm taking a
latitude and longitude
and I'm querying for
restaurants in that.
And now the Google
Maps app is launching,
it's going to this location, and
it's highlighting restaurants
at that location.
So say I'm building a travel app
or something along those lines
and I want one of the
activities in my app
to be that people can
see a map of restaurants,
instead of me building that for
myself, the package is doing it
for me.
The Google Maps app
is doing that for me.
But wait, there's more.
It gets better.
Now I can actually parse
different real things.
Like, so if I want
to say, for example,
do navigation instead of-- so
say maybe I have a restaurant
myself and I want people to
be able to navigate, you know,
to my restaurant, now within
this URI structure I can say
it's a google.navigation?q--
q was what again?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Query?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Query.
Thank you.
And then I can
specify to navigate
to a particular location.
In this case, Taronga
Zoo in Sydney, Australia.
He's lucky enough
to live in Sydney.
He can go there any time.
I wish I could go, because I
really want to see a koala.
And I Ankur has taught me all
about drop bears that drop out
of trees and they
look like koalas,
but they're really fierce.
And something tells me
they're not real, though.
Are they real?
ANKUR KOTWAL: They're real.
They're totally real.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
So, again, if I want
to do navigation
and I want the Google Maps app
to handle navigation for me,
this is all I have to do.
Very, very simple; very,
very straightforward.
And then finally, my very, very
favorite Google technology.
When I first interviewed for
Google, one of the things
they ask you is, OK, tell us
your favorite Google technology
and, you know, tell us some
things about it and, you know,
maybe how you'd improve it.
And I wear my
heart on my sleeve.
My absolute favorite
is Google Street View.
So, again, if I want
to have a Street View,
like maybe a-- I do volunteer
work in Seattle, where I live,
for it's like a
youth hockey group
and we have a
couple of ice rinks.
And ice rinks a really
big, expensive places,
so you have to put them a
little bit out of the way.
You can't put them
in city centers.
And sometimes it's
hard for people
to find the ice rink, so, like,
something like a Street View
so people can see, hey,
navigate to this location.
This is what it's going to
look like from the street,
this is our ice
rink, and that kind
of thing, that's where Street
View just works brilliantly.
And you can also view inside
places with Street View.
So you can see what it's like.
So we put, like, a
couple of our ice
rinks that the actual
ice sheets that we did,
like, a surround view that
you could navigate into it
with Street View with that.
And it was just fabulous.
And now people can see
what the facility is like.
And, again, if I want to
have a Street View launch,
all I have to do is
create a URI like this.
You know google.streetview
dot something and two numbers,
latitude and longitude
again, and I'm
getting all of that
functionality done for me
without me doing anything.
Pretty cool, right?
For lazy developers like me.
Now, this doesn't just
work with Android.
We also can make
this work with iOS.
Now, not everybody on iOS has
the Google Maps app installed,
of course.
So using URL schemes on iOS,
we can do something like this.
Now, in this case you see I
clicked that Launch button
and what happened is in
this scenario is I did not
have Google Maps installed
on the emulator--
I recorded this off
of the emulator--
so it falls back
gracefully to Safari
and uses Google
Maps within Safari.
Pretty cool.
So let's take a look at what
the code for that would be.
Now, I'm sorry, I'm a
little bit more old school
when it comes iOS.
I'm an Objective C guy.
I haven't become a fan
of Taylor Swift yet.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
Hey, they laughed at it.
ANKUR KOTWAL: That's
one out of, like, 15.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
OK, we had a debate whether
they would like that one.
So they did.
So, you know, in our
Objective C all I have to do
is I'm going to create
a string of my location,
and it has the latitude
and longitude in it.
And then the URL
scheme prefix for that,
the same as you saw
on the Android slide,
where I'm saying it's
com.googlemaps:// latitude,
longitude.
Also, sorry, there
was a zoom here.
When you talk about maps,
when you want to render maps,
so if you imagine a camera up
in outer space looking down
on the map, and
then your zoom level
is the closer you get to the
map, the more detail you see.
So this was zoom equals 14.
So that view on the last slide
that we had of New York City
was like I'm zoomed right
down rather than viewing
New York City from orbit.
So I'm just saying, you
know, com.googlemaps,
here's my latitude,
here's my longitude,
here's my zoom level.
And I'm going to create
a URL out of that.
If you're an Objective C-er,
if you're an iOS developer,
how you will launch
an application
is you use the UI application
shared application,
and then you open a URL on that.
So now I've tried
to open a URL, which
is prefixed by com.googlemaps.
Now, maybe this URL will
open, maybe it won't.
When it will open is when the
Google Maps app is installed.
When it won't open is when
the Google Maps app is not
installed.
So in this case I say,
hey, if it fails, I'm just
going to fall back to
http://maps.google.com/?=
and then my location
parameter from the beginning,
the latitude,
longitude, and zoom.
And that's when Safari opened,
went to Google Maps for me,
and showed that
particular location.
So, again, Google Maps is
really doing everything for me
as a developer in this case,
and I'm writing minimal code.
It would be great if the
Google Maps app was installed
and then I get all the richness
from that, but if it's not,
I still have the maps
within safari itself,
within my browser itself.
So I think this is a really,
really cool technology.
And, again, for
lazy people like me,
you know, who just
want to delegate,
who want to have Google
Maps do everything,
you know, we have these
things that we can do--
the URL schemes, the activities
that we can launch on Android,
and that type of stuff.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Hey, Laurence?
What if I don't want
users to get out of my app
and I want to keep
them in my app?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Then we incorporate.
ANKUR KOTWAL: OK.
Tell us all about it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
here is a case of,
I just want a simple map.
I want the simple map.
I want it in my application.
As Ankur said, I don't
want to drive people
out of my application
to the Google Maps app,
or I don't want
to drive them out
of my application
to the browser.
How do I get a map
in my application,
and how do I make it as
simple as possible to use?
Well, let's take a
look at what we have.
First of all is the
Web Static Maps API,
and this is a pretty
cool API where, I mean,
if I were to summarize
it, you give a URL,
you get an image back
containing a map.
But it's not just
going to be a standard,
boring map that's the
same as everybody else's.
It can be customized.
Here you can see the one on
the left has been customized
and has been themed
so it's this really
nice arty black and white.
So maybe if your site has that
kind of design language in it,
your map could do
the same thing.
The center one is
a satellite image.
I don't know where it's of.
Can anybody guess?
Is that Iceland or?
I'm not sure, but it
looks really pretty.
There's lots of fjords there.
And so, again, you can set
it to be a satellite map.
So maybe you want
to-- I don't know,
maybe you want to show
off, like, landscape.
It's a real estate app
or something like that
and you want to show off
the beautiful landscape
around the house.
So those kind of things, you
can show satellite images.
And then finally, you
can also set it so
that you could have a routing.
So a, you know, how to
get from A to B. So,
again, if I go
back to my example
that I was talking about earlier
on of the hockey organization
that I volunteer with, this one
is really, really great for us
because we want, on
our website, to have
people be able to find
where our rinks are.
And it's like, here's
navigation from various points.
And so it makes it-- you
know, it's a static map
that we're embedding.
I don't have to worry about
embedding logic in a website.
putting lots of JavaScript
and all that kind of thing.
I have a URL that I call,
I could iframe it in,
and I get what I want on there.
So that's that Web
Static Maps API.
Again, it's not taking
me away from my site
or not taking me away from
my app to something else,
it's just giving me
in-line what I have.
And I'm incorporating
Google Maps's functionality
into my own site.
Then there's the Embed API.
And here's where we take
it a little bit further.
So instead of it
being a static map,
I'm getting all
the functionality
that you would be
used to if you were
using Google Maps in the
browser independently.
So things such as roads,
navigation, traffic conditions,
all those kind of things
that you see on the left,
it's just iframed in.
In this case, the source is
google.com/maps/ something,
and I can get whatever I want
based on what's available
in the API.
As you can see on
the left here, I
have navigation around London.
And as you can see on the right,
I have my favorite technology,
it's Street View.
And here is the example.
This is a really
beautiful restaurant.
I don't know where it is.
Do you know where that is?
ANKUR KOTWAL: I don't.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
So if like, for example, we
have this really beautiful
restaurant-- so if I was
operating a restaurant
and I wanted people to see
how beautiful it is inside
of my restaurant, instead
of just telling them
or instead of having
static photos on my site,
I could embed the Street View
of the inside of my restaurant
so people can pan around,
they can zoom around,
they can step around
inside the restaurant.
And they can really,
really get an experience
for what it would be like to
be in my awesome restaurant.
I hope the cooking is
as good as the pictures.
So then there's Autocomplete.
So have you ever
gone onto a phone
and you've had to start
typing in an address,
and it's like, you know, typing
with thumbs the way that you do
is, like, I want to go to
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry, it's like,
what's the address of that?
I have no idea.
It's somewhere in Scotland.
The Autocomplete,
what that will do
is once I start typing-- in
this case I was typing Hogwarts,
and now I'm typing the
Eiffel Tower-- what that's
going to do for me is
once I start typing,
we have a places API
and we have places data
in Google Maps that will
then come back and start
autocompleting based
on what I'm typing.
If I start typing H-O-G for
Hogwarts, all of the Hogwartses
around are going to be
listed, and I can pick one
and get address details back.
Anybody ever been
to the Eiffel Tower?
Did you know the address
of it before you saw it
on this slide?
Right?
We don't know the address
of places like that.
You know, you go to Paris and
you see this great, big tower
and you know that's
the Eiffel Tower.
Or you ask people
how to get there.
But if you want
the address of it,
it's really, really
hard to find.
So if, I in this case, started
typing Eiffel Tower, then
the autocomplete-- if I'm
dropping the Autocomplete
widget into my
application-- that's
going to give me data back
about the Eiffel Tower
once the user's selected it.
And that's how on this one I was
able to find the address of it
and the latitude and
longitude of it as well.
And the code for this--
oh, it's cropped off here.
It's not cropped off
there, thankfully.
So the code for
this is on Android,
you know, we have this
place Autocomplete widget,
and we start an
activity for that.
And then that
activity, once the user
has finished typing in stuff,
is going to get a callback.
So on the left,
the activity result
code that you can see at
the bottom, whenever you're
in Android, if you
start an activity
and you get a callback,
that callback's
always going to
contain the data.
And you're going to
have data and you're
going to cast it into
the relevant object.
And in this case,
you know, my data
that's coming back for me is
actually going to be a place,
and the place is
something that's
an object within the Places API.
And then from that I can
start querying metadata
around that place.
In the example that I
showed, the metadata
was things like the address
and the latitude and longitude.
But, for example, if
it's a restaurant,
you can start seeing
photographs of it,
you can start
seeing reviews, you
can start seeing
links to the site,
menus, all of those
kind of things.
And there are tons of
entities, not just restaurants.
There's everything from A to
Z, from accountants to zoos,
available within that API.
And then iOS it's
very, very similar.
You can see the
pattern is the same.
On iOS on my autocomplete
press button in this case,
I'm going to start to
view controller, which
was a-- I have to read it out--
it's a GMS autocomplete view
controller.
And what that's going to do
is that's presenting the UI,
as we saw in the video.
And when the user
types in something,
gets an address back,
they've selected the Hogwarts
that they want to go to, then
this will call you back with a
did auto complete with place.
And from that you can then
pull the place details.
And you can see the
last line of code there.
I'm just saying, you know,
a string place details is
the place name itself.
So while the user might have
just typed H-O-G for Hogwarts,
they were able to get
all these details back
and the name was being
returned in one of them.
Very, very straightforward.
Very simple code for
lazy programmers like me.
So next is the PlacePicker.
So now, for example,
I'm in a location
and I'm walking around in
downtown-- this is Rome,
I believe.
So if I'm walking
around in downtown Rome
and I know that there
are places around me,
wouldn't it be nice
if I had, like,
an app that I could
take out and I can start
looking at all these places?
And it's, like, highlighting
interesting things for me
from cafes to tourist sites?
And as I move around
and I touch on them
and I get the details
back about it?
And if I play it, we
can see this in action.
There we go.
So, like, I'm moving around and
I see, oh, look, this place.
It's updating my location.
It's finding things
that are around me.
I'm able to drop the
pin on some of these
and find out interesting
details about it.
Or I can find, like, the
places that are near me.
You'll see the list
at the bottom updates
what's available around there.
I pick some of those places,
and I get details about that.
And I can do all
of this and I can
get all of this
functionality out of the box
by writing very,
very little code.
So let's look at the code.
Looks very similar to the
previous slide, right?
You know, in Android I'm
going to start an activity,
and this activity is going
to be a PlacePicker activity.
And whenever in Android
you start an activity,
the user has done
something, all of that
functionality that you saw is
built into that PlacePicker
activity.
And when I get a callback
from that and the data,
then I can cast
that into a place.
And that place object then
has all the properties
and all the methods
that will allow
me to pull information
about that place
and light up my app with them.
Maybe my app is showing
menus, or maybe my app
is showing photos or
those kind of things,
and all that data is going
to be available there.
All I had to do as a developer
was use the PlacePicker
activity, launch a PlacePicker
activity, catch the callback,
back, parse the data.
And in iOS very, very similar;
very, very straightforward.
There is an object called a GMS
PlacePicker config in the SDK--
sorry.
And the PlacePicker config
is used to configure details
about my place, and then I
launch a GMS PlacePicker object
passing that configuration.
And that configuration might
be-- you saw in my example
I was in Rome-- the
configuration would be, like,
location about Rome.
That type of thing.
I will launch my
PlacePicker, and then
I get a callback from that, and
the callback, as you can see,
has a GMS place object.
And that GMS place
object, again,
has all those properties
that I can parse for name,
address, all those goodies.
So I'm the lazy one,
he's the hardworking one.
So we're going to move
on to the next layer,
and that's, like, when we start
moving deeper into integration
and we start moving deeper into
using mapping functionality
in our applications.
And, Ankur, can you--
ANKUR KOTWAL: Sure.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Take it away.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So as you
can see, the journey
that we've been
taking you on so far
is about getting you
started with the Maps APIs
with little effort and adding
little bits of user experience
to your app.
And now we're starting
to get to the point
where you really want
some more customizability
and you want that flexibility
to really tailor the experience.
No pun intended for his
Taylor Swift comment earlier.
LAURENCE MORONEY: You
can tailor it in Swift.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yes, you can.
So I'm going to start off by
talking about the JS Maps API
v3.
So this screenshot
here is actually
from an app we just
recently wrote.
And for those of you
that are here at I/O,
please go check out
the Geo Sandbox,
because what we did was
built a bus tracker.
So if you took any
of the Google buses
to get to and from
I/O this year,
you'll notice that there were
some QR codes on the window
and you could actually
track your journey.
And here we're using
the Maps API v3
to provide an experience that
you can see is very customized.
We're using styled maps to
use a color scheme that's
actually matching the
theme of I/O for the year.
But we also have custom markers.
We've used polylines
at different points,
and actually we've integrated
other APIs as well,
which I will talk about
a little bit later.
Things like the directions API.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
really like how the map
itself fades into the
background so that you can focus
on what's important, right?
The bus stops and where
the buses are now.
That they really pop.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Exactly.
And it's this API that's
taking you beyond just
dropping a map in your app.
It's really styling
the experience
to match whatever else
you're building around it,
because the map may only be
a part of your app or site.
On Android, we also
offer a similar API.
And where Laurence
has had his chance
to tell you what his
favorite API is, which was?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Street View.
Anybody else love Street View?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Only a few
people love Street View.
For me, my favorite
API is actually
a subset of the Android and
iOS APIs, and it's the camera.
So here you can
see a top-down map.
You're used to seeing it before.
You've seen it many times.
But on Android and iOS, we give
you really, really good control
of that camera.
So have a look at
this video here,
and you'll start to see
that what we're doing
is really changing the
position of the camera.
And this is downtown LA.
And now that we've
zoomed in far enough
and changed our
angles of view, you'll
see those 3D buildings pop up.
This feels like a
real place, right?
It's not that top-down map.
In fact, if you
think about maps,
we've been using them
for hundreds of years
and they've always
been top-down.
In the digital age we get
to provide such amazing user
experiences.
And so, to me, this is
my favorite part of it,
because when I build an
app with a map in it,
I really want the user to
feel like they're there.
And you can actually
achieve this sort of effect
with, again, very little code.
Here's the Android code.
We create a camera
position using the builder.
Bearing will basically help
us rotate as to which degree
we're facing.
Target is obviously the
location that we're looking at.
But it's Tilt that makes
the big difference to me.
So Tilt basically helps
us move our camera
and face it in-- and
offer some depth.
And that's how you're starting
to see more of the horizon.
And that's really, to
me, the magic value
that made that sort of
experience in that last demo
possible.
And, of course, Zoom Level
brings you in or further out,
as Laurence described.
But you'll notice that as we
were moving in downtown LA
from point to point, the camera
was smoothly moving there.
And that's because we
weren't calling Move Camera,
we were calling Animate Camera.
And the nice thing
about Animate Camera
is that when you pass in a
new camera position to it,
it will work out what
the difference is
between the current viewport
and the target viewport
and it will animate
nicely there.
It'll animate each
of those values
that you see up there with
the Camera Position Builder.
So please do use it.
It's a great way to provide good
navigation through your apps.
Of course, with iOS,
you are able to achieve
a similar type of effect.
Here we've zoomed in far enough
that, again, we have those 3D
buildings, we're able
to zoom in further
and interact with it, and so on.
And so this, to me,
is really those maps
coming alive and providing
that customizable experience
that I talked about earlier.
The code for iOS is, again
very, very similar to Android.
We have this GMS
Camera Position Object.
We're able to pass in a
bunch of parameters to it.
Here our Tilt is actually
called Viewing Angle,
but we're able to
customize that, too.
And then we pass it in to
get a map view out of it.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
We iOS developers
are a bit more literal.
ANKUR KOTWAL: You like lots of
characters in your parameter
names.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We've
got beautiful keyboards.
We like to type on them.
ANKUR KOTWAL: So moving
right along, Lawrence.
Another thing that you might
want to be doing with your maps
is that you want to
put markers on there,
but, like, if you look
at this example here,
we have some
restaurants in Rome,
and here I actually did a
search for "Italian restaurants
in Rome."
It turns out there's
quite a few of them.
I was shocked.
This is not a great
user experience, right?
Like, you want your users to
be able to explore and discover
restaurants, but putting in
a thousand markers on a map,
it's not much fun for anybody.
So instead, I'm
going to show you
marker clustering, which we
provide with a library called
Android Maps Util.
And you'll see as we zoom,
those numeric markers
start to split and more
markers come out of it.
And then when we
zoom, these markers
come together and
form into clusters.
It's actually much,
much nicer to be
able to see this kind
of zoomed out view
where you know where there's
lots and lots of markers
around.
And it's very obvious to users.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it's
great for perf was well, right?
ANKUR KOTWAL: Yeah.
Performance, absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Like, in this view,
instead of seeing 200
pins and tracking them
as you pan the map around,
you're seeing one blob.
ANKUR KOTWAL: Absolutely.
The cool thing about
marker clustering
is that implementing
it often results
in less code than when you're
managing your markers yourself.
So let's have a
quick look at that.
As I mentioned, we have this
Android Maps Utils Library.
So in our Gradle configuration,
we just add that library in.
And then we have to go and
implement this interface called
ClusterItem.
So in our case, we had
a list of restaurants,
and we would have had,
like, a Java object
that was the restaurant itself.
We just implement this interface
that provides this method
getPosition, and it just returns
this latitude and longitude.
So you're probably already
tracking this data anyway,
just add that
interface, take out
all of your own marker code, and
instantiate a Cluster Manager.
You're associating the
Cluster Manager to the map,
and you're also telling the
map that you want the Cluster
Manager to get these callbacks
whenever the viewpoint changes,
or if the user is clicking
any of these markers.
So that it's able
to manage, you know,
like as the Zoom Levels change
or the viewport changes,
it's able to work out what needs
to be done with your markers.
And then you just give
your Cluster Manager
those data items.
In our case, they
were restaurants.
So you're just passing in
an object that implements
that interface, and that's it.
It'll manage the rest for you.
You'll get that experience with
just these few lines of code.
It's pretty amazing.
But, of course,
Marker Clustering
isn't the only way to deal
with lots and lots of markers.
The other one is heat maps.
So here what we've done
is kind of tried to see,
in Rome again, where
those restaurants are.
Because if you think about it,
where there's more restaurants
are really where the
more crowded areas are.
It's where more tourists
are going to be,
and if you are a tourist,
it's probably where
all the attractions are, right?
So here, if we have a look at
the demo again, as we zoom in,
it's generating new heat maps.
Those heat maps start to
split up as we zoom in,
because, again, we're
starting to see the density
of these various restaurants.
And it just, like,
results in a-- I mean,
this is-- I clearly
am not a designer
because I've been told
my choice of colors
wasn't quite the best, but
it's totally customizable.
I intentionally went with this
sort of stand-out set of colors
to show you that you can
customize that gradient that's
shown there.
And the code for this
is similar to what
we saw for Marker Clustering.
Add a library, the same
Android Maps Utils Library,
but this time
you're instantiating
a HeatMapTileProvider, and
you're associating your data
items with it.
And then you're telling
the map that my tile
overlay will be provided by
that Heat Map Tile Provider.
That's it.
You don't need to do
anything more than that.
It will manage the rest for you.
So that's pretty
cool, and that's
some of the
customization that you
get at that integration layer.
But many of us developers
are like, you know what?
I don't want you to manage any
of the visualizations for me.
I know what I'm doing.
I just want the raw
data, and I will
be able to put it on a map.
So orchestration is really
about you wanting that raw data
and taking full control.
So let's have a look at some
of the APIs that enable that.
And it really starts off
with the web services
that we provide.
I'm going to talk about the
Directions API to start with.
So remember I mentioned that bus
tracker that we built earlier?
That bus tracker,
what it's doing
is that we stuck an Android
device on each of those buses,
and it's reporting its
location to a Firebase
real-time database.
And then our web app is
consuming those locations.
We know where the
buses are going to go,
and we're feeding it in
to the Directions API
to give all the attendees
at I/O accurate times
as to how long it's going to
take for you to get to I/O
or get back to your
hotel from I/O.
And buy "accurate times," we're
taking into account things
like the traffic conditions, the
real time traffic conditions.
And for buses that are
not taking off till later
in the day, we're
using a feature
that we call Predictive
Travel Times.
So we're able to forecast what
the traffic conditions are
likely to be like when you
leave maybe this afternoon
to go to the airport, to
go back to your homes.
So the Directions API actually
gives you tons and tons
of great functionality.
And actually, in terms
of your own apps,
if you're a fitness app and
it's about running or cycling,
we can give you
walking directions,
cycling directions,
we can give you public
transport directions as well.
You can also customize
your waypoints.
So maybe you're getting
from point A to point B,
but you have to make
some stops along the way.
So imagine you're building
a logistics type app,
asset tracking type
app, waypoints really,
really help you there.
So Directions API is a great
way to get that information,
and you can get it
back as JSON or XML
and then pause it and
display it on a Google Map
whether it's on the
web, Android, or iOS.
Laurence mentioned the
Places API, Autocomplete,
and PlacePicker earlier on.
We actually have a web
service for this as well.
And don't worry too
much if you can't
read the text on the left.
The idea is that with
just a fairly short URL,
we're able to give you a ton
of information about the places
that meet that criteria.
So here we've just asked
for restaurants in Sydney.
And you can start
to see that we are
getting a lot of information.
It's paginated as well, so
you'll get a few hits at a time
and you can request the
next batch as you go.
Places API is really,
really amazing
because we don't think
of our location in terms
of latitudes and longitudes.
As Laurence said,
we mostly don't even
think of our location
in terms of an address.
We use an address
when we're trying
to get somewhere specific,
somewhere that's unfamiliar.
But really often we think about
where we are based on its name,
because as people, we tend to
think of our location by name.
And the Places API provides
a fantastic set of tools
to be able to help you bridge
that gap with your users.
So it's really,
really worthwhile
looking at this web service.
On Android and iOS, we also
offer a Native Places API.
So where you saw earlier we had
Autocomplete in PlacePicker,
those were predefined
experiences.
They were widgets that you
could just drop into your app.
But maybe you want to customize
the look and feel, right?
You don't have to use
those PlacePickers.
I highly recommend you do
because it's very little effort
to use them, but
let's say you have
a special need where
you need the underlying
data on those devices.
So we have these APIs, so
you'll see on Android and iOS
there they have similar
names, but the top ones,
getCurrentPlace and
currentPlaceWithCallback,
they give you the
same functionality.
They list a number of
places that are around you.
And so I'm going to show you
this demo on the left-hand side
here.
And what it is is that we're
driving along on the freeway,
and the list at the bottom is
just a list of the place names
as well as the
value that we return
to that we call likelihood.
And you can think of
it like a probability.
What is the probability that
the user is at that place?
So let me show you what
that demo looks like.
It's really quick.
And particularly, look
at that first item.
You'll see the
probability values
of that one are changing while
the others are sort of moving
up and down.
So have a look at that.
It's a very short demo.
So as we're going
along this freeway,
the device is using
all of its sensors.
It's using GPS, it's using Wi-Fi
scans, where you have beacons,
it's able to use BLE beacons--
Bluetooth, sorry-- beacons
to give your location
quite accurately.
But we're able to put other
smarts in there as well.
Are you really going to
be at that coffee shop
at 1:00 AM when that coffee
shop closed at 9:00 PM?
Unlikely.
And we're able to put
those sorts of smarts
in in determining the
user's current place,
because we have that set of
data in the Places Database.
And we've used machine
learning to really tune what
those likely values are.
So suddenly with just,
again, these few APIs, you're
able to get very
accurate information
about where the user is and
then present them with options.
Maybe your app is something
that helps the users explore
their surroundings, and so
getCurrentPlace is a great way
to show, here are restaurants.
Here are tourist attractions.
Maybe when we were in Rome.
And getAutocompletePredictions
is the underlying API
that we saw that sort of
powers the Autocomplete widget
earlier.
So as your user is typing in
their keystrokes, you can say,
well, what are the Autocomplete
Predictions for this?
And present them how
you like to your users.
We love our smartphones, but one
thing that we take for granted
is actually the
GPS sensor in them.
We use it a lot.
We rely on it a lot, but
what you might not realize
is that the GPS sensors in our
phones are not very accurate.
So Laurence took a drive
around the Google Sydney office
here, and he--
LAURENCE MORONEY: I promise
I was sober, although it
doesn't look like it.
ANKUR KOTWAL: He was driving
around our Sydney office here,
and if you look at
those orange points,
he was actually in
a car on the road,
yet the sensor on this
phone is telling us
that he drove through
a park, on the field,
and through a casino.
Now, I've been worried about
Laurence's gambling problems,
but I didn't think he
would do it in a car.
And I was right.
And so what we find is that
this was a common problem.
Developers came to
us and said, look,
while I know that my
users are in a vehicle,
we know they're on a road,
this GPS tends to be noisy.
We know that we need
a straight line,
but the GPS points
tend to be more zigzag.
Can you help us out?
The Roads API helps
you achieve this.
So now what we do is we
take these orange points,
we throw it into the Roads
API, and we plot them here
as green points, because that's
what the Roads API's giving us
back.
And you'll see now these
points are actually
following the road.
In fact, we can insert.
With the Roads API, you
may get back more points
than what you input,
because when you're
taking curved roads, you want
to have a few more points coming
through so it's tracking
nicely and you're
able to plot that well.
So let's get rid of these
noisy orange points,
but I wanted to
show both of them
to show you the
delta between them.
And here, this is
more-- this is exactly
what Laurence's route was.
So the Roads API's
a good way for you
to be able to snap your
drivers to their roads.
Now, we have tons and
tons of web services.
We've just covered
a few of them.
But the thing is, we want you
to be able to consume them
in the languages that you use
on your server-side components.
Let me forewarn you
that with web services,
you should not consume them
directly in the mobile apps.
They're designed to be
consumed server-side.
They're protected by
an API key, and you
don't want that API
key being distributed
in your mobile apps.
So please do proxy them
through the web servers,
through your cloud servers.
But we have some
client libraries
that we produce for Go,
for Java, and for Python
so that you can consume them
in whichever of these languages
that you prefer.
If your favorite
languages aren't on here,
let us know what you'd like
and we can take that back
to the team.
Before we wrap up, I want
to thank you for being here
and I want to show you something
new that we're kicking off
today, or just recently.
We've had some
feedback in the past
that you would love to
know more about what are
the things we're working on.
So we're now announcing
a new beta program.
So if you could go to
this link and sign up,
you have the opportunity
to join a community
of other like-minded developers.
And we will reach
out to you as we're
launching betas of new
and upcoming features
of the Maps API.
And this is, of course,
across all our apps,
all of our platforms.
But the best part of
this is that they're
pre-launch features.
So your feedback helps
us to shape the product.
We want to take that
feedback on board,
we want you to tell us which
use cases it's meeting well,
which use cases that
we're maybe not meeting
as well, we want you to give us
feedback on the quality of it,
and in turn, we're
able to share with you
a bit more about our roadmap.
So as of today-- so if
you're watching on YouTube,
as of today at I/O,
the form is open.
But we will be
taking developers,
accepting developers,
in batches,
so if you find at some point
that that form is closed,
don't worry.
We will open it up over time
as new APIs are being launched.
I hope today that you've had a
good look at the various APIs
that we offer, and you can
see your own apps and sites
slotting into one or
more of these layers
and seeing which of
these layers are most
relevant to your development.
Thank you very much.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]